kyle freeland will make his eighth start
of the year and i'm sure his confidence
is back where you'd expect it to be
after his last two outings a 0.82 e.r.a
2-2
swung on
[Applause]
comes with it at 82 miles an hour it
acts a lot like that back foot slider
and with two outs that'll bring up nolan
and you know what well done by the fans
that's three straight days we said
yesterday hey it's a new audience and
three straight day taking the time to
acknowledge the fans and they not only
hit they were counts that's inside so
back-to-back walks wade leblanc gets his
second outing uses a two-seam sinker
mostly sinker cutter oh and two from
wade leblanc
go use him good job very good change up
sells it with the arm speed gets him way
out on the front foot and there's
nothing he can do and now it's dazza the
left fielder 2-2 and he struck him out
back-to-back case wade leblanc here is
harrison bader with two pitch
puts it in play
he may beat this out and
he is out and waving and waggling that
finger and saying uh-uh as mcmahon made
it very close and we'll see they are
going to challenge it the decision
and they're gonna say he is safe on gone
for edmundo sosa vader is picked off
makes a good throw and the tag by still
very athletic play by story because he
had a ways to go to get to the back i
like the way trevor takes his because
it's a better throw and an easier throw
for the first baseman but how about this
blind tag trevor blanc leading off here
in the third
to two swing made a miss
leblanc for his second strikeout edmond
switch hitter batting right
tommy
has extra bases coming up that'll go all
the way to the wall
and a one-out double
dude tommy's got such quick hands
pulls him in right there gets something
going here with him so here's
goldschmidt two outs edmund at third one
one pitch swung on and pulled to the
left side slowly hit mcmahon has it near
the bag
over to first and a good pick out of the
dirt by cj crone and that retires the
side ryan mcmahon on the move makes a
nice play colin arenado the third
baseman for saint louis
[Applause]
center field
deep
hampton
tucks it away 415 feet from home play
kirsten bader the center fielder for
saint louis
strikeout of bader well kyle has a
second half that's his third strikeout
curveball
didn't get the depth that he wanted to
but he got the right result brendan
rodgers nine game on base streak the 3-1
pitch is grounded to the left side
arenado goes to his left
and bobbled it a little bit on the
exchange but came up with it cleanly and
throws out roy rogers at first base two
men on and here comes elias diaz the one
two
there's six there's four
low throw back to goldie to the plate
and there's three to two yeah that's how
you draw it up nice turn
tries to go with the throw on the run
goldie doesn't get the scoop gets a
favorable bounce gets it with the bare
hand and throws a bullet to yachty to
cut down mcmahon at the plate one
outweighed leblanc he struck out
swinging his first time
diving stop mcmahon throw to first
himself
good instincts good reaction and then
the throwing arm and that was
an on the mark throw the rockies will
need a two out hit that'll bring up daza
leblanc takes his time reading signs now
he's ready the kick the pitch a swing
and a fly ball hit well center field
vader moving back he's on the track to
make the catch a long out for dazza
leaving owings in scoring position and
the rockies are all for five with
runners in scoring position tonight one
away here in the saint louis sixth
and ryan mcmahon he hasn't had to play
in a while
how good was that
he made that look really easy he did
matt catches his ball and the natural
momentum is behind you so it's just
easier to spin
and that helps it create a little
momentum towards first so the rogers
trying to extend is on base straight to
10. ball two strikes on brendan
takes strike three call big pitch right
on the corners he's been living on the
edges mike schill does not want leblanc
to face cj crone again crone has walked
twice ryan helsley pitched yesterday 20
pitches he's going and
[Applause]
safe
ball was dropped there's a low throw by
helsley
everything's good he steps off and then
just buries the ball down in the dirt he
threw a change up elias diaz the
schedule to hit her
diaz on the first pitch pops it up
[Applause]
and paul deyoung has it and that'll send
us to the seventh inning julie
taking the baseball in the top of the
seven here's paul deyoung scoreless game
in the seventh
miss shot seen strikes out to you
elevated fastball that's where you need
to throw the elevated fast forward matt
carpenter
will lead off next day he comes in for
sosa in the double switch hard throwing
left hander this is uh
cabrera so rymel tapia pinch hitting for
jolice shacine with one out bases empty
in the seventh
and this toward the hole
base hit the pull this
fastball get enough of it to squeeze it
fast paul goldsmith one out and two on
for daza
daza ground ball to nola bobbled for a
moment
and
battled out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
runners at the corners for story
[Applause]
[Music]
so with two outs it's been a double by
carlson base hit by goldschmidt to
center run batted in his 44th a walk to
arenado he's on base for the third time
and now it's yadier molino
molina hits it up the middle base hit
goldie will score
cuts the lead to three to two
elena delivers again a hard hit ground
ball up the middle two
for dylan carlson two of two
ball games
[Applause]